that we have our daylight saving time
when we tick over into it as we get
further into summer and you're waking up
and it's like wow the Sun has been up
for a long time we should adjust the
clocks to make that work but it doesn't
not everyone likes it as we've just
established okay how does this change
there we go
think about how you articulate that
question in a second but I'm gonna come
back to that just have a look over the
map again there are some really weird
and unusual things if you start to look
a bit closer so basically speaking each
color is a time zone do you notice the
lines are not Wiggly and wonky why do
you think that is they're not all
straight like this straight in some
portions but then they kind of all curve
around what you think you did here yeah
exactly right for certain parts certain
countries if for example we have a look
at Africa you can see you've got this um
here's his Greenwich Mean Time or
coordinated Universal Time zero but then
as you move east this is plus one this
section these guys are plus two and this
is plus three so it makes sense that
even though this line goes this way and
it goes up to the top if you're halfway
through our G Rhea you just like walking
across you like Auto myclock right so
everywhere in Algeria is the same time
zone
okay and that principle of taking a
country and sort of you know having a
single time zone is something which is
taken to its extreme over here okay so
who's lived in China before ends up one
- just - okay that's right so have a
look all of China all of China is plus
eight now just have a look at the
overall map have a look at the overall
map you can see plus eight down here
Philippines and Malaysia that kind of
thing the plus eight comes from Beijing
right there's the capital okay
but quite some time ago the Chinese
government decided okay we're all gonna
be on Beijing time all of China is on
Beijing time what issues might that
cause if the entire country China's big
is on Beijing
in time yeah what do you reckon yep yeah
yeah yeah this it's really weird over
here in the western part of China so in
fact this city here Arun she is Michael
it's a very large city I'm in Russia
during winter you know how we're used to
the Sun rises later in winter what time
do you think arises in winter roughly
for us I mean I reckon it's somewhere
between six and seven maybe much more
the seven end of things in summer in a
Ruchi the Sun rises around ten because
in fact it's you know it's that's
actually the time over here
ten o'clock so there it's like well into
mid-morning but because they're so far
away look it's like plus 6 over here and
plus 10 over there a 4 hour difference
that other countries recognize but from
one part of China to the next it's all
plus eight right but not all countries
do this if you have a look over here the
US famously because they've got also a
similar landmass how many time zones are
they across the u.s. yeah there are four
you can see them there you've got I
think we call this Eastern Time and then
they call this Pacific time right so if
you've seen PST as like an abbreviation
if you like to watch us shows or
anything like that sometimes they'll put
that there and then you've got Central
Time as well in the middle so these are
really interesting to me you've got all
kinds of other weird sorts of things
one last question let's go back to the
simplified map here one last question we
haven't dealt with is this guy what is
this the date line okay what's the date
line about why is it there hmm what do
you reckon na
we're showing how's the time difference
yep yeah yep so what we want is let's
just go back to let's go back to here
zip zip zip we want everywhere on the
planet to exist within the same 24-hour
period right now in fact I'm getting on
a plane on Sunday and I'm going to Perth
so I'm going to hours backwards right
backwards as it were so if I if I leave
at in fact my flight is at 8:30 on
Sunday morning so 8:30 on Sunday morning
we're going to take off and my plane is
going to immediately say oh it's
actually 6:30 in Perth time so the plane
immediately changes to the local time of
the destination now think about this
imagine if I just started flying and
just like kept going right it's like do
I keep on winding my clock back forever
can I just like go into the past into
last week and the answer is no you can't
because what happens when you pass the
dateline yeah it's the same time on the
clock but it's a different day so
actually you would flip forward a day as
you transfer from here to here does that
make sense it's why if you have a look
at where we are and where the date line
is we are one of the very first in fact
we're probably the you know biggest
major city to celebrate New Year's every
single year
yeah then the major there the first
major country to describe well Japan is
here I think so New Zealand's yeah a
good like hour before then okay last
question wait
yep to go back so so as you go this way
you go forward but once you pass the
Dateline you're going to go into the
previous day because think about it this
way okay let's think about in fact and
this is a very like you'll be able to
look up online tools to help you with
this but it's a very literal problem I
was trying to do Skype I was trying to
teleconference with someone in where was
he waiting live california which i think
is around here right now because i was
trying to line it i was looking at my
calendar and let's try to line up times
with him and i realized that i was
talking about a different day to what he
was talking my hour I should say 8:00
a.m. for our time was his 1:00 p.m. the
previous day right so as you travel this
way you're mostly going forward in time
on the clock but once you pass the line
BAM 24 hours immediately goes backward
okay so it is we're in our usual so I
said again oh you mean if you just kind
of hover here I think the answer is you
get really confused so which by the way
which by the way is why the line whips
around right so that it avoids major
land masses in countries
yeah well this International Dateline
here if you have a look at this landmass
over here it's that same landmass so
they've just expanded it so you can see
it from both perspectives from an
Eastern perspective and a westward one
okay